[Musique]
alors je viens du Liban et c'est un tout
petit pays au bord de la Méditerranée et
quand je dis aux gens que je viens de ce
pays souvent j'ai deux réactions soit on
me dit à Michel dort à la cuisine
libanaise
soit on me dit quel peuple résilient
c'est vrai en fait
nos âmes nous avons 15 ans de guerre
civile hyper inflation une des plus
grandes explosions non nucléaire qui a
touché la capitale
nous avons une crise économique c'est
une des plus grandes depuis la moitié du
19e siècle et pourtant on a cette
réputation de renaître de nos cendres
alors si cette métaphore était si
inspirante pourquoi alors on s'en sort
pas est-ce que ce n'est pas dans cette
résilience même que se trouve une partie
du problème
je suis neuroscientifique et quand on
aborde cette notion de résilience on
considère que notre cerveau a évolué
pour garder un certain niveau
d'équilibre un stress ce serait tout ce
qui nous est loin et de notre équilibre
alors on a une réponse au stress pour
retrouver l'équilibre et si on arrive à
retrouver l'équilibre on peut dire que
notre système a été résilient donne un
exemple imaginez un ancêtre qui est
tranquille dans le champ il entend un
bruit dans les arbres donc il assume que
c'est un prédateur il a intérêt et donc
il va avoir une réponse au stress il va
avoir le que le cœur qui va vite il va
respirer plus fort il va transpirer
pourquoi parce qu'il prépare ses muscles
un sauver sa peau et dans cette course
notre ancêtre il n'a pas intérêt à
dépenser d'énergie sur des fonctions
secondaires nos prioritaires il va pas
draguer il va pas cister il va pas
digérer il va pas réparer ses tissus
s'ils se blesse il on va regarder sa
blessure parce que logiquement à quoi ça
sert si jamais tu es un danger de survie
de regarder ta blessure et il va pas se
poser des questions existentielles
est-ce que c'est la meilleure version de
moi-même pourquoi je vis dans ce
champion tout ça ça va paraître
non prioritaire et pourtant c'est pas
grave parce que ça va durer quelques
minutes soit il a fait le repas du
prédateur soit il a échappé et en tout
cas une fois que ce stress est passé il
peut retrouver tous l'équilibre et
toutes ces fonctions reprennent on peut
dire notre ancêtre a fait preuve de
résilience alors le problème c'est que
notre cerveau ne fait pas de différence
entre un stress physique et un stress
psychologique ça veut dire là par
exemple si je perds le fil de mes idées
devant vous je vais avoir le cœur qui
bat je vais respirer je vais avoir les
mains moindes je vais avoir les joues
rouges parce que mon corps pense que il
y a des prédateurs dans la salle par
contre ce serait absurde que je me mette
à courir
parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas de
différence entre votre jugement votre
possible jugement de moi-même entre une
exclusion sociale l'incertitude la perte
de contrôle et une blessure physique
alors imaginez que nos stress
psychologiques durent des semaines des
mois et que notre réponse au stress met
de la même façon en veille nos fonctions
physiologiques prioritaires ça devient
un peu aisé de comprendre pourquoi nos
stress psychologique nous rendent
malades
alors on a une réponse au stress non
adaptée et qui presque nous tue parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est des maladies
cardiovasculaires c'est du diabète c'est
de cancer de maladies immunitaires qu'on
meurt alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
comment on guérit
si je pose la question à des guides ou
des coachs de développement personnel
vont dire respirent
en charge TA santé mentale par la
nutrition le sommeil l'exercice vous
avez des ateliers qui vous apprennent à
dire non des ateliers qui vous
apprennent à rire des ateliers qui vous
apprennent à vous débarrasser des
personnes toxiques bref vous avez tout
ce que vous pouvez imaginer aujourd'hui
comme stratégie pour reprendre le
contrôle sur nos émotions et c'est ce
qu'on propose aussi aux personnes qui
souffrent des co-anxiété ou de burn-out
professionnel trouver un moyen d'aller
bien et à première vue franchement
pourquoi pas c'est vrai que nous avons
la capacité d'agir sur notre discours
interne et de se dire que je peux donc
agir sur ma santé physique et mentale
même la pensée positive confus tige
fonctionne des fois là par exemple je
peux me dire
ce n'est qu'une conférence ma mère
m'aimera quand même quoi qu'il arrive et
ça va réduire ma réponse au stress c'est
un peu ce que je me suis dit avant de
rentrer d'ailleurs
mais derrière cette apparence noble et
louable il y a des effets pernicieux
parce que
quand vous croyez que votre résilience
provient de vos pratiques individuelles
pouvez finir par quoi que vous êtes
libre que donc vous attribuez à
vous-même et aux autres une liberté qui
vous détache du reste et donc vous
finissez par croire que vous êtes
responsable de ce que vous êtes et de ce
que vous allez devenir alors pourquoi
pas franchement ça nous donne un aspect
prometteur que nous pouvons agir sur
nous-mêmes
mais ça peut nous mener à une obsession
de considérer les enjeux sociaux en
termes d'obstacles internes et donc de
psychologie ce qui ne tient pas de la
psychologie
parce que tout le tient pas de votre
psychologie intérieure notre santé
mentale ne n'est pas du vide on peut pas
considérer que le traumatisme de guerre
de mes proches libanais ou les co
anxiété ou le burn-out professionnel
comme un rhume qu'on a attrapé parce
qu'on s'est baladé au vent sans bien se
couvrir cette façon d'aborder la santé
mentale et la résilience comme un
concept individuel fini donc par blâmer
l'individu nous détourner des structures
et nous inviter qu'à agir sur notre état
d'esprit mais nos cerveau sont façonnés
par la société et si la société va mal
il est tout à fait normal que nous
allions mal et quand on va mal parce que
la société va mal on a besoin de plus
que de penser positivement sinon ce
serait comme si je dis à mon ancêtre
tourne-toi regarde l'ancêtre regarde les
autres regarde ton prédateur et engage
une communication non violente
ou si je dis à une personne qui souffre
dès qu'on anxiété c'est les forêts qui
brûlent c'est que une métaphore de tes
échecs amoureux ou à une personne qui
souffre burn out professionnel qu'il
faut qu'elle connecte avec son enfant
intérieur pour qu'elles comprennent la
colère qu'elle vit face à l'harcèlement
moral qu'elle subit ou carrément à une
personne qui a une fracture à la jambe
de prendre un antidouleur puissant
comme ça elle peut marcher comme si de
rien n'était
c'est là où la résilience devient
dangereuse quand c'est une quête d'aller
bien mais qui ignore la source du mal
quand les pratiques de développement
personnel vont réduire votre douleur
subjective mais sans guérir la source du
mal
nous avons besoin de plus que d'aller
bien parce que aucune étreinte aux
arbres
ne va sauver nos forêts brûlées mais une
réflexion radicale et collective de nos
modes de production et de consommation
et aucune retraite spirituelle
ne va apaiser
mes amis libanais mais une justice
n'arrêt de la corruption et une
reconstruction du tissu social et aucune
séance de yoga ne va être vraiment de
l'aide pour une personne qui souffre
d'un mois de professionnelle si on
réfléchit pas le milieu de travail et le
rendre
aligné avec notre besoin d'autonomie de
reconnaissance et de respect de notre
valeur humaine
l'empereur stoïcien Marc Aurèle il dit
que ce qui n'est pas bon pour un essaim
d'abeilles n'est pas bon pour l'abeille
vous allez jamais voir une abeille
tranquille dans un champ alors que son
médecin brûle alors il est temps
que nous considérons la santé mentale
comme quelque chose qui n'est pas réduit
à notre cerveau et à notre corps mais
qui prend en compte l'environnement dans
lequel nous vivons
est-ce que je suis en train de vous dire
de ne pas vous soigner au contraire dans
un monde aussi abîmé qui vous invite à
vous surmener à préférer le succès au
bonheur c'est un droit
de nous soigner d'ailleurs
le mouvement de self-care ou de soins de
soie est né dans les cercles
d'activistes afro-américains des années
80 mais après il a été récupéré par le
broyeur du capitalisme des industries de
fitness de bien-être et aujourd'hui on
parle d'économie de l'expérience qui
vous dit que plus vous faites des
expériences et plus vous approchez de la
mer version de vous-même
et donc c'est devenu une injonction à
devenir des personnes optimisées or nous
devons récupérer le droit de nous
reposer pas parce que ça nous rend plus
profond ou plus lucide mais parce que
nous pouvons un enfant par exemple qui
transface des de l'eau d'un vase à
l'autre il le fait pas parce que ça peut
me permettre de développer sa motricité
fine il le fait parce que il en a envie
et nos pratiques de soins ne doivent pas
être coûteuses et sophistiquée parce que
le monde nous offre plein d'opportunités
simples et peut-être que nous n'avons
rien en inventé de plus efficace que les
formes invisibles de solidarité prenez
par exemple un primate
dans une pièce où le stresser au bout
d'un moment il a des ulcères mais s'il
subit le même stress en présence
d'autres primates il a moins d'ulcère et
pour nous les études sont unanimes que
vous ayez une maladie cardiovasculaire
ou que vous ayez un discours à faire
devant un public la présence de vos
proches vous rend la vie plus douce
alors peut-être en attendant que nous
rendions le monde plus juste plutôt que
nous nous renfermions sur nous-mêmes
dans des pratiques de développement
personnel qui nous invitent à nous
replier
si on te refonctionnements on peut
plutôt nous évader de nous-mêmes nous
oublions un peu nous prendre moins au
sérieux et retrouver une simple douceur
dans le fait que nos destins individuels
tirent des racines interminables vers
l'expérience des autres
donc nous soigner oui je ne dis rien
contre au contraire c'est nécessaire
mais nos problèmes en tout cas leur
majorité
et structurelle et donc nous n'avons
qu'une insu de les résoudre
collectivement alors peut-être que ce
que je vous dis vous paraît compliqué
parce que oui c'est plus simple
d'appeler une chamane qui fait des
pratiques amazoniennes mais qui
s'appelle Alexandra
Corinne qui habite dans le lot mais en
fait
c'est pas vrai parce que c'est
libérateur de se dire que c'est pas à
vous tout seul de trouver les solutions
et aussi c'est libérateurs de se dire
que vos épreuves
n'arrive pas nécessairement pour une
raison ce n'est pas nécessairement des
leçons et donc nous n'avons pas à nous
élever à devenir plus lucide et a
considérer que ces épreuves sont là pour
nous apprendre quelque chose parce que
ça rajoute à nos épreuves la culpabilité
de ne pas en faire des tremplins vers
des meilleurs versions de soi et enfin
c'est un grand soulagement de se dire
que nous n'avons pas à nous concilier
avec un monde abimé qu'il est légitime
qu'on soit en colère qu'on ait peur
qu'on soit triste qu'on soit en manque
qu'on soit en deuil que ce ne sont pas
des signes que vous n'avez pas encore
trouvé la bonne thérapie
et ce ne sont pas des névroses privées
sont au contraire des réactions utiles
et saines un monde qui ne va pas merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]